[Music]
Hey
good to see you again just going to work
we're in downtown Manhattan driving up
to the Hayden Planetarium on the Upper
West Side so let's do this
hello see no thanks for joining me
New York City has like 8 million people
in it I mean it's it has kind of had
that number like for the last 100 years
it's fluctuated 7 million 9 million this
have been about 8 million Oh guess who I
see
dude what's up where you going oh well I
was waiting on a 103 alright to go up to
the Hayden Planetarium cuz I'm not I'm
not fancy enough to roll around in a
super cool SUV Oh dr. Neil deGrasse
Tyson so but uh okay let me just be
honest I'm stalking you Neil oh and Jeff
um I've just been waiting here all day
cuz I know your car I know you weren't
you I worry about you sometimes oh it's
just like so you so you're coming up to
that's good
of course it's good of course because
here so I'm gonna make a big confession
about the planetarium at which ones are
the director yeah of the Hayden
Planetarium my day job that's your date
which changes the lives of young people
every single day
you know I so yes I think it does that
but the people who need a life change
for the grown-ups
okay so then alright so here's the deal
I'm one of those grown-ups oh okay
because yeah my wife has taken the kids
for the planetary Oh
twice you come through a building so I'm
saying oh dude you mean you'd really
okay alright I am okay sir I'm
officially impressed for your New York
driving
I'm just saying cuz otherwise I got to
go like five lights around around a
corner I'm a fan so officially impressed
because this is some old down-low
Sonique new york like you got to live
here forever know the situation cut
through this building which has a
barrier that drops so that anyone
looking to cut through here would be
like well I'm trapped
you're trapped but you know that the
barrier goes up automatically because
it's an exit only you got it pedestrians
didn't know they let me just say this I
I know for you guys you in the front
seat that was a gangster ass movement
just pull behind the wheel of a car that
was that's like New York gangster
driving right there straight up dude
that was amazing all right so now we're
right back here right quick indeed
that's amazing
those two cops up there yeah they're
cops on a little motorcycles okay I know
you are sitting here not as much anymore
they'll do it at their age and stuff
dude their scooter cops though that's a
little I don't know if that's like a
little embarrassing well but in New York
we don't have Harley cops like you know
ya have another place yeah because you
can't get around to the traffic like I
guess the scooters more nimble yeah yeah
I'm kind of dart in and out mm-hmm but
it looks a little funny to see a cop on
a scooter you think when they go home
daddy what did you do I Drive a school a
school I guess it's better to be in a
scooter cop when you're like a kick
scooter or you just ya know but to wheel
scooter is better than a three wheel
scooter never see the 300 yeah I did
yeah it's like you know it's almost like
they stole it from the kindergarten how
say yeah when when your scooter has
training wheels let me just say give up
give up one life when you screw you're
driving the scooter with training wheels
give up one life okay that's that's my
advice to you